hey guys what you're about to see is the
full quiz that was included in my ai
lights novel video if you haven't seen
that video already go watch it now
because it's going to make this video
make a lot more sense
but in a nutshell i designed an ai that
would make
fake light novel titles and i tested
some of my best friends joey the anime
man
and connor c-dog va to see if they could
tell the difference between an ai
generated title
and a real light novel title and you can
also test yourself as you go along to
see if you do as well as them that's
pretty much it if you've already watched
the original video this would all make
sense
but anyway let's crack on with it so
here i am now with the boys
thank you very much for joining me today
for you know this experiment
what is this what a rare collab this is
this is i think the first collab i put
on my own channel i think this is the
first time i'm on your channel
i think so like dead ass hell yeah so
basically what we're going to be doing
today is we're going to be playing
humans versus robots so i've already
i've already explained what we're doing
but to explain to you guys what we're
doing
um i have a bunch of titles and some of
them
are real light novel titles and some of
them
are ai generated titles that are made by
the ai that i've made
right i'm going to be quite good at this
really so okay
so firstly this is for science right so
this is for science experiment this is
this is an experiment so
basically i was thinking about how to do
this and i think the best way to go
about this
is you both are on one team so if you
guess correctly
then the humans get a point oh okay if
you lose then the ai gets the point
right we have to like agree yeah well
that never happened
and so i mean do you want to know some
basics about how this ai was built
sure okay so because what i really want
to do here is really
try to see if you can logically deduce
which one
was it made by a human and which one was
made by an ai so this ai
i took a base that basically learnt
english
by trolling through millions and
millions of articles on the internet
right so theoretically it knows english
but it knows
english through wikipedia articles and
you know reddit posts and twitter posts
and all that kind of jazz
it's how shakespeare like that yeah
exactly so you know it does know
pop culture references and stuff like
that through the internet
and on top of this base i fed it
thousands and thousands of light novel
titles okay to see if it can piece
together
any patterns about how light novels are
made the common themes and everything so
that's that's how it so that's how it
learnt on top of that base
okay i mean i just gotta say there are
some light novel titles that i've read
where it's like there is no way a human
came up with that
yeah well it might as well be ai we will
see we will see again because
because so what i will ask you joey
i'm gonna ask you a favor because i do i
am legitimately curious about
the logical process that you if you can
logically deduce which one's made by a
human or not
okay so if you have read it because most
of these are on book walker
okay so if you do know the english title
on bookwalker
then i would ask that you know you i
don't say anything you leave it to
comment or
just just say that you know if not if
you just know the japanese titles or
something
we'll see how well it translates okay so
first one is uh
real or fake so you're gonna be given i
have a bunch of titles and i chose like
simpler sounding titles so this is more
on concept
right does this concept sound like a
real light level title
okay um and i'm gonna show you a bunch
uh
it's in no particular order so could uh
there's
might be more ai generated ones there
might be more
um uh real ones and also the order is
completely random as well
so don't try to deduce if i would put
like x amount of
in a row because i literally randomized
it myself okay
okay so i i feel that i i've only ever
consumed the light novels
through the titles i don't play them all
so i you know i'm just like this is
gonna be like i guess
exactly what i'm used to yeah okay let's
go for it first one
campfire cooking in another world with
my absurd skill
oh i know this is a million times harder
than i thought
oh my god see this is the problem as
well that i think like translation
errors could make
not not translation errors but the way
it's been translated yeah make it sound
more because there are a lot of like
english translated titles
don't sound legit okay i will say that
uh
since this is from the book walker
database yeah um
everything is an official translation
official translations don't help but
some of them are jank is [ __ ]
some of the official trends like so i'm
aspire to so what that has so twice in
the title
that's not how english works uh oh my
god look
honestly i would if my gut initially
says this is fake but i could see it
being real i
i think it's fake just because um i'm
not sure why
really it has all the elements
that you will find in a light novel
title like my absurd skill thing is
throwing me off a little bit i don't
know why i think that's the most legit
part of the time really yeah because
especially with isakai light novels it's
getting to the point where
it's not so much like the most it's a
synopsis
yeah well it's it's not so much like
with my incredibly overpowered skill
it's it's
the title is being told by the
protagonist it's almost first person
right it's weird
i could see campfire cooking as well
being some form of japanese translations
i feel like i feel like no one ever says
campfire cooking in english i'm just
trying to think like
where would the plot go right like
like how how would you build a plot off
of this concept i don't know i don't
really like novels
i'm just trying to think like there's
some [ __ ] weird light novels out
there but i'm just like okay you have
this absurd skill
and you can't fight cook right what was
your initial gut reaction when you saw
that
fake i i thought yeah just because i
don't know where this part would go yeah
so i'm gonna i'm gonna say fake yeah
i'll see folks
okay i can tell you that it is
real
where does this plot go ginger fried
pork and the legendary beast [ __ ] off
with that subtitle
this is definitely like it sounds like
that because of translation 100
100 yeah that sounds like not real
english
it does it doesn't doesn't like it it's
like someone's attempted
i would be curious to see what the
original actual japanese
title for this badass wolf is dead ass
holding an armpit
in his mouth okay next one all right so
that's that's one
ai i don't like this already i was born
as a dragonite but i
am your maid oh sorry i was born as a
demon knight but i am your maid
that sounds fake am i going to be doing
this again right again
i want to say oh it's either
there's one point about this where i'm
thinking that this is real but this
could
also easily be the ai just learning and
that's the fact that it ends in a period
because there's been like this common
trend recently where
light novel titles especially it's like
it's not just a title
it's a [ __ ] sentence right and it
ends
in a period i i think this is too real
like this is too too like like novelly
to be real you know what i mean it's not
it's not weird enough
oh i mean i think you're like you're
giving too much credit to libels
i feel like a lot of them have even
weirder things than this and this is too
straightforward
no i think i think the quirk i think the
quirk is the fact that like you know
he was born as a demon knight this
really powerful thing but at the same
time he's the moment
it's a demon knight well it's like it's
a knight that also has
demon powers right and i am your mate i
could see it being real i could also see
it being fake
but i think i don't know i'm really like
this period man
like you'll be fake no i'm gonna say
it's real okay
you know we we we if you want we can
change it we can change it to joey and
one of us no no no no we can we can we
can
we can work together we're gonna work
together okay i'll show sugar okay
that's what i mean like there's no like
i [ __ ] my my
10 year old sister on a trampoline you
know your view of light novels is
[ __ ] whack that's what they all sound
like to me you know
all right next one no matter what other
person you are i'll do my best to keep
you all safe in paradise
[Music]
it's too broken to be fake
yeah i i think it's got to be fake no no
i think it's
it's it's so blue i'm not i'm not going
to let the period swing anymore
we clearly the ai has learnt that we've
established that the ai knows how to put
a period yeah yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] is no matter what other
person you are what is that that's not a
that's not a real sentence
maybe maybe it's like a split
personality thing no it's i'll do my
best to keep you all safe
what is this this car okay this can't be
real but if it is
they need to fix the translation yeah
it's either a real one with a whack
translation or it's fake yeah but
i'm i'm gonna say fake i'm gonna say
fake you are
correct yeah okay thank god like i
booked
[Music]
all right all right that's good next one
the hitchhiker's guide to the easter egg
that sounds real that sounds real
straight up
really i thought that was straight up i
think that's
i think i mean it's clearly a parody on
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy right
what is this [ __ ] with the period what
is this font with the
the what is that t that's that the tesla
logo
i think it's i think this is fake i
don't know i don't know i have a i
haven't said he fed it wikipedia
articles
yeah yeah i could see it being fake i
don't know like i
feel right if there was a light novel
that was straight up parroting
hitchhikers guys to the galaxy i would
have known about it
you think so because i love you but
coincidental
i do think real but i i think real
honestly
you think yeah i don't know man it's
again it's
okay well if it's if it's fake we know
the period's a giveaway yeah you're
right
let's say real let's say real let's see
real correct
nice two two two two okay
that doesn't look real i i i looked at
the title
and i thought this can't be real i've
got the wrong list on it yeah so there's
dead
there's six [ __ ] authors
and author that's the creator of re-zero
is it some kind of reference to
the hitches
our crappy social game club is gonna
make the most epic game
that's fake i i want that to be fake
purely for the like the sake of
people writing this [ __ ] dude i kind of
wanted to be real just to see
a light novel title that has the word
epic in it now that has to be fake that
has to be fake
a crappy social game club is going to
make the most epic game
oh my god it's the most epic that's
throwing me
the most stupid the mochas god said
they've been taught real
lingo and real you know yeah internet
slang and i feel like no
no translator would ever translate the
most the most epic
the most that is something that you
would you would translate if you read on
a forum
but again no but but again it's that
whole thing of like how light novel
titles are becoming
more more and more like not proper
japanese
yeah like it's become like titles now
have become more like
casual japanese so there's a very good
likelihood of using the words crappy and
most epic
but even um the cooking one was like my
absurd skill absurd isn't the slang word
no no one's like yo that was absurd you
know what i mean
if you're like my skill i think this is
fake just off the
way the english is being used it's like
hello fellow kids okay
the back of my head it says real but for
the sake of the game let's say fake yeah
okay
i told you there was something about it
i was like
what is the japanese name not gonna lie
as well there was in the back of my head
i was like i feel like i've heard of
this before yeah yeah
i i definitely recognize this girl
okay there's no most epic so that's just
a [ __ ] shitty translation translation
all right god damn it next one we've
gotten like one two
one right two right so it's two three
two to the ai so okay
is it even the distribution or are you
not telling us i'm not turning okay okay
saving god and the world so i am a cat
and i am the strongest this is probably
gonna be real and like a garbage
translation
right yeah i feel the same way i feel
the same way
because yeah again this is
again this is either no this doesn't
make any sense
this is just a bunch of gibberish i
think the ai no but here's the thing
the fact that this another train in
light novel titles is the fact that
there are more than one sentence did you
did you did the capitalization on these
slides is that random or
uh no this i completely pasted it how
how you know how either the real or the
a i said
both one of them does capital am and one
of them doesn't this has to be fake and
if this is real someone
someone needs to lose their job all
right you're right you're right well i'd
say
fake you're right thank god could you
imagine i'd be like what
no i was about to say real but your
observation
otherwise
[Music]
the unwanted virginity of a genius
i want to read this if it's real what
does this mean
what does this what does this mean this
doesn't make any sense
so basically it's like there's a genius
and
he i don't know wants to no one wants
his virginity
because he's a dick maybe uh i i feel
like this is real
or or or either the protagonist is is
like you know has a friend who's a
genius and doesn't want it
just in selly enough or i'm like japan
would make this
yeah this this seems like a real one
this yeah uh let's say real you want to
go through i have a really weird feeling
it's vape let's say real [ __ ] i'm gonna
say real
honestly i've i've read this title i
i've read this i'm like i want to read
this yeah
this this actually sounds this is a
super legit title right i mean can i can
i can i write this down
japan please make this i'll i'll make it
because
because i've read this i'm just like
that sounds like a really unique
like rom-com right yeah it's like a
genius and
he's he doesn't want his virginity
that's that's how i took it yeah yeah
yeah yeah right yeah he's a genius and
he doesn't want his virginity because
but but none of the girls won yeah but
none of the girls won him that's that's
how i read this yeah
so we're like what three four now to the
end [ __ ] me all right yeah let's go
okay so we are so we're changing up the
game a little bit okay
so those were the um those were like the
shorter titles
right those shorter titles yeah those
those were the shorter titles okay yeah
i can believe that so now i try to train
the ai to make
longer titles you see some of the like
longer more convoluted light novel
titles
i wanted to see if there was a method to
the madness if there was any logic
between some of the
really batshit crazy stupid titles right
so
you're gonna be given two titles and you
need to tell me which one is the fake
one and which one is the real one okay
okay so it's
it's an actual showdown okay okay um so
the first one
is i started off with something a bit
easier it's a bit of is a bit of a
popular one but
i was reincarnated in another world now
i became a villainess
okay my next my next life as a
villainess all
roots lead to doom i get i i know this
one
wait one of them's ai and one of them
one of those real ones how does that
work
how does the did you feed it to the ai
the original title and just taught to
make a new one
um no i actually just picked some titles
that that
i'm pretty sure this is the real one
yeah the one on the right is the reason
i've heard this before yeah okay
you're all right yeah the reason i
picked this one is because i've read
uh i saw this one come up and i thought
this is already a title yeah
i'm i'm going crazy this is already a
title and i googled it and i realized
that was the title depending on who's
translating the title it could be this
yeah
when you showed the i didn't know
exactly what's happening but yeah oh
yeah i know that light novel
yeah i i saw this i was like
if anything this seems more like the
real one than this one
all right the next one is do with the
index franchise so
um right see which one of this
is a real index spin-off okay
a certain magical heavy zashi wadashi
deals with a simple
killer princess marriage circumstances
okay
a certain magical index reunion with my
reincarnated god and the automation
what the [ __ ] i should know this because
i've read
like close to everything from music
is that zashiki warashi what
is this like yokai it's basically this
like it's usually the portrayal of this
girl
who is basically like kind of stuck in a
particular room because they have strong
feelings about the room and it's like
this
it's this like kind of evil spirit kind
of thing so that's a legit thing
okay which leads me to believe that this
might be the real one
because with this with this computer use
a cold one
curious i think probably do you think so
honestly yeah it might
i i just i mean i mean look obviously
this one is
the more convoluted yeah this is the
simpler one so i think
you would intentionally think oh that's
the computer one because that's more
yeah
right but i do think this might be the
computer one i think this might be the
computer i do think this one
because i feel like i would have read
this
i would have because i've read not all
of index but i've read most of these
this sounds
just broken enough to be real this one
no no no no no no
this one yeah yeah and the automation
what is the god in the automation no i
can totally believe this
that's why i think this is the real one
what this one yeah i think so
really oh no sorry this is the fake one
sorry yeah i think i think the one on
the left is the real one
yeah so we're going to say left one as a
rule all right correct
yes all right two hour two on the second
game so
far dude look at this [ __ ] car i know
right
what the [ __ ] i was going through the
list and i thought oh my god
i saw this and i thought i got the wrong
list like i thought i mixed up the list
right because i had the list of all the
real level titles
and i went through i saw this i was like
wait a minute this is the uh generated
one okay
reading this in japanese is like actual
like i'm
getting a stroke trying to read it i
feel like
japanese just does not translate when
it's longer
who the [ __ ] remembers a title like that
oh what is your favorite oh well it's
actually the
all right next one all right okay now
this one doesn't have any pre-existing
anime adaptations or franchises so we're
going straight in blind now okay
seriously seeking sister ultimate
vampire princess just wants little
sister
plenty of service will be provided
gravitation war chronicle an exiled
wizard princess
another chronicle for raising mobs
that's gotta be fake
that's rad reads too poorly which leads
me to believe that that's real
i i vampire princess
just wants little sister semicolon
plenty of service will be provided what
the [ __ ] is you you i feel like you
underestimate
the stupidness of like those titles this
makes too much sense
okay i have a theory maybe the this one
had a colon right
and it's in the exact same format as the
other fake one yeah
so if if this one is fake then maybe the
the
the bot likes doing it this way well no
here's the thing though like like i feel
with the index thing right
this one seemed the most legit because
all of the index light novel titles do
use a call
right so i feel like it's either the ai
is learning
the use of the colon and the use of like
cut sentences in the title
or this is a real one i do think that's
real i this one this one reads
so bizarrely the thing is though when i
look at both of these and i'm thinking
of like
the japanese cover of it yeah i see this
being more of a reality than this one
all right i'll go with your gut then
i'll okay if i'm wrong
then i revoke everything i just said but
i feel like the left one is the real all
right fine look at that then
you're right yes it's
so dumb i like how the i like how you
got to this by
saying which one makes the least amount
of sense yeah you know but this one
makes too much sense that's what i'm
saying
i feel like i feel like it's hard to
teach a computer to make
just the right about yeah that's i mean
that's that's kind of why i wanted to do
this because i'm just like
i can it can't is there a way that it
can deduce how these sentences make
sense because to me i look at this and
i'm just like this makes no [ __ ] like
that's what it's such a specific kind of
broken reading that isn't broken but it
it's just nowhere near natural
yeah because i looked at seriously
seeking systems and i'm like that's
really easy to say in japanese
it does like that that first part made
me think yeah this seems
very yeah yeah i could see this on the
shelf
god it looks like [ __ ] all right uh next
one
my littles uh my big sister lives in a
fantasy world five the strongest little
brothers commonplace
encounter with the bizarre my big sister
lives in another world
where are my dogs where are my sexist
teachers
i want that to be real i want that to be
real so bad
i want the right one to be real so bad
okay first of all
number five is throwing me off
i listen it's the the colons again and
the fake one
the call it loves doing the color yeah
but again like i've never seen
let's tune around i've never seen a
numbering system
in the title it's usually like this
thing
five all right yeah and they rarely ever
use numbers
right i've only probably only seen like
yeah let's go with the my big sister
lives in another world
even as stupid as that reads i could see
it i could see i can see this one
let's go with that let's go to the right
one uh bro the right one being what the
one is real no
unfortunately not it's the left one
and i i think this is part of a series
so right right um i think because this
is this is how
the title was listed in book walker's
listings
um wait so is this is this is this this
whole title volume five or is this
number five of this series volume one
it's just volume five
so that means it's just [ __ ] titling
because normally it would be
my big sister lives in a fantasy world
the strongest little brother blah blah
blah
five right that's how it normally would
be
the right one sounds like a legit line
title i would read that
all right i think this is the last one
for this one
okay um let's get it let's go let's nail
it
crimson princess is not a witch too
a night at the end of days the complete
story of the world's strongest dungeon
okay i'm a behemoth an s ranked monster
but
mistaken for a cat i live as an elf elf
elf girls pets yeah i just read so like
so many like novels yeah this one's this
is like yeah this reads like a lie no
this is fake the bot deserves a very big
round of applause
this is so good that i i would believe
this is a title crimson princess is not
a witch a knight the s-rank monster is
what's really convincing yeah
it's real yeah i think that that's
something that i would be super that is
a hundred percent an easy guy yeah i
would be
super impressed if the bot knew how to
do that yeah all right yeah god feeling
i'm going to say the right one is real
me too okay um you are correct
no this part apparently i uh pasted the
wrong
title but yeah you're correct yeah
frank monster thing seems like such
weird because it's
yeah it's such bizarre knowledge that
only like a gamer would use yeah yeah
yeah
so i mean that was basically all the
slides so
you absolutely destroyed the ai on the
longer titles
yeah but it's the shorter titles where
the ai wants it's hard man
it is true the titles are hard yeah yeah
it's because with the shorter titles
there are some
real-life novel titles that don't sound
like real lightning the more the more
like
obviously the more words in there the
more room for life exactly yeah yeah
exactly and it's such a weird logic to
the long light novel titles that you
don't
see it consciously but i wanted to see
if an ai could replicate it and
i feel like the biggest thing i got out
of this is ai titles make too much sense
compared to light number titles
uh that honestly yeah the ai is too
intelligent
um as an added bonus um so another
function of this ai is that
i could add a name for it to begin with
so
basically i could make light novel
titles with your guys's names
apparently yeah okay hell yeah so out of
ten i wanted you to judge
if you would read these okay so first
thing okay
first thing i want to say i just said it
your first names because i tried feeding
it my name
and it did not recognize gans as a name
at all
it didn't recognize our entire subreddit
didn't recognize gans as a name didn't
recognize giggup as a name
recognize grant as a name
all right the first one freaked me out
because the first one is
joey biz how i got naked in another
world
yes i don't know if i don't know how it
got bitter how [ __ ] they get [ __ ]
i have no
[ __ ] color i thought you put biz in
no i did not put bis in
the ai put joey biz and i didn't see
that at light novel that's yeah that's
eight out of ten yeah how i got naked in
another world i would do that
second one joey on the job sex worker
the harsh the harsh mysteries of harry
potter yes
uh that's not a lie novel that's a
fantastic sex slave
like did you just write a fan fiction
right here and just named it yeah
yeah it might have been scrolling
through like uh archive our own yeah
by joey hell yes all right for connor's
one
connor and the dopius wives of harsh
mistress summershacks
i'm just like i don't know how it knows
that connor wants to make a meal pencil
but the ai somehow figured that out i
love
it sounds like a word doesn't it yeah a
dopey ass
it's so close this is actually my
favorite one all right
connor wants to be a hero but it's
actually a dick
part two the world's strongest gamer
that's so weirdly spot-on
[Applause]
i feel called out i'm in this photo and
i don't like it this is so
on brand that i i didn't know
how it came up with this fight if
someone wrote a light novel about the
chess tournament this would be it
yeah please i like out of every
fictional light novel title that we've
mentioned today
i want someone to make fan art of this
title
i want
when i put connor's name down there were
so many titles to do with connor being a
gamer
i don't know how it like let's go like
something about joey it it
it it kind of made yeah it made me into
like a [ __ ] prostitute
you're like a harem protagonist and
conor was just like an esekai gamer
protagonist
i don't know how the ai figured that out
amazing
but uh anyway thank you very much boys
for being part of this yeah that was
really interesting
yeah that was good and uh back to
whatever i'm gonna do next
and that was it thank you again to joey
and connor for taking part if you want
to check out their channels click the
link in the description
and also if you watch this without
having watched the original video well i
guess now is the time to go watch the
original video right
all right i'll keep it short and sweet
i've got nothing further to say hope you
enjoyed the video i've been gigguk and
i'll see you all
next time